there's no school today in much of the
Denver area while police search for a
young woman considered to be armed and
extremely dangerous
who's made what's called a credible
threat at least 18 districts closed
hundreds of schools last night and told
more than five hundred five hundred
thousand students to stay home just a
few days before the anniversary of the
Columbine High School shootings and
police believe that Seoul Police is
fascinated with the events of Columbine
that happened before she was even born
students at Columbine High and 21 other
schools were locked inside for hours
yesterday after the threat was made
public Barry Petersen is at the FBI
office in Denver Barry good morning good
morning well the FBI says it is working
with state and local law enforcement to
try to find this woman they call it a
manhunt and now with all of these school
districts closed across this whole
region tens of thousands of parents are
trying to figure out what to do with
their kids
after spending Tuesday afternoon on
lockout students at Columbine and other
high schools safely filed out of
classrooms it was a scene frightening ly
reminiscent of almost 20 years ago when
12 students and one teacher were killed
the FBI says this woman soeul Pais flew
from South Florida to Colorado on Monday
we identified that she departed the
airport and went to a store where she
did procure a weapon she obtained a
pump-action shotgun and ammunition
officials say Pais posed a credible
threat to Denver area schools and may be
focused on Columbine she has had an
infatuation with Columbine and the
perpetrators of Columbine she did not
make any specific threats to a specific
school but her comments her actions that
we have heard about from others tend to
cause us great concern that she may pose
a threat to a school CBS station WFOR in
Miami spoke with a man claiming to be
pices father
more than 20 other schools were put on
lockout meeting doors were locked while
classes continued inside students said
the order came with little warning so
many things were just rolling through my
head like if somebody had a gun
something bad could have been happening
out there we didn't know a lot of
information and knowing it was so close
to the Columbine shooting was something
that was a little rattling the threat
comes just four days before the 20th
anniversary of that mass shooting I know
that this opens a wound especially on an
anniversary week for those families who
were most deeply impacted by this two
things to keep in mind here so far this
woman has not broken any laws as far as
we know and to because of the
anniversary law enforcement was already
on high alert for something like this
which is why the reaction has been so
vigorous Gail okay very good point to
make she hasn't broken laws but she sure
is scaring a lot of people thank you
very much